suffering is almost a catalyst right to
push us on the path and what I see
happen on a collective level more more
people are suffering because there's
something bigger happened let's start
from the spiritual perspective there's a
divine force the super mental
consciousness if she open as she opened
a moment ago Yoga would say is trying to
anchor itself during this time of
transition right but it is springing up
everything that is not a line of truth
right so it is not this like all of a
sudden everything will be in paradise
but it brings up everything we have not
looked at we have no we have avoided and
a lot of a lot of people that is very
intense yeah are they going through a
lot of tribulations you know and then a
person lives emotionally but it needs
the vessel needs to clear itself right
within so we can truly anchor the divine
yes and that's just a very intense
process right now boom what's up
everyone welcome to simulation I'm your
host Don Satya we are on site in the
beautiful taupe anga California we are
now going to be talking about spiritual
awakening we have Bernard gloom there
joining us on the show hi Bernard Hey
huh thanks for having me on again for
round three this time round three yeah
that's what happens our spirits go and
level up and then they come back and
engage and see what has evolved mist
inspired when it's transpired yes yes
those who don't know Bernards background
where as the founder piercing the veil
of reality which is a collection of
various articles videos and essays
ranging from esotericism via cult
psychology history and shamanism
relating to the matrix control system
the process of awakening the evolution
of consciousness in the time of
transition we are in right now
you can find the link in the bio below
to veil of reality calm as well as the
YouTube page all right Bernard it's been
a lot of fun evolving for me since the
last time we talked on the show I've
definitely had a deeper more divine
connection to source to all that is to
that oneness that feeling and it's been
so beautiful that it's even become this
first principle thing that I'm just
starting to say how ridiculous is it
that so many of us are disconnected
from that source we're so disconnected
from that nature and even the indigenous
wisdom around the world are saying that
same thing that our disconnection from
that nature is the reason why we have
all the issues that have arisen in our
world we speak about the connection to
source what that is for you and also our
disconnection from nature yeah it is all
interrelated connection to source then
we bring in words like the divine or God
which God in itself can be quite a
trigger word it has been for me in my
own process because I feel will all of
us become disillusioned or disappointed
with dogmatic religion the major
religions of this God outside ourselves
you know supposedly this authority
ruling over us and punishing us if we're
sinful and we see how much damage death
and and everything disaster dogmatic
religion has created over the years of
the missionaries and all of that so you
know I can understand that people you
know remove themselves from anything to
do with anything divine or God and then
people jump the ship and become atheists
so to speak right then the materialistic
view shift to the other polarity out the
pole but then as I like to say the
babies being thrown out with the bath
water and then and in my own process
I've also you have always had done
deeper work psychological work spiritual
work as well but then you know
throughout the years I'm also came face
to face with the divine of God and
aligning with this higher power right
and seeing that something else you know
I need to align myself with and that is
the divine to will let the divine work
through me like I'm like a vessel like a
channel but there's nothing outside of
myself right oh it is outside myself
inside that is all that is its pantheism
all is God exactly and expresses itself
himself herself in various disguises you
know and we're just playing this
hide-and-seek and but our world you know
we also in the dark' just the Kali Yuga
where we're very much removed from God
from the divine which we can never be
fully separated from it's just the
illusion
we live in the world our modern world
the first we'll be so proud over just so
much removed from H and spirit you know
we live in a very artificial life that
is not in tune of who we truly are and
that's how also you know these forces
what I talk about the majors controls is
there are other cold forces how they
operate to keep us spiritually [ __ ]
so to speak rather keep especially
disconnected so they can use us as a
food source through the manipulations
and all of that and you know keep us
polarizing each other
keep us in constant conflict fear
physical survival and divide and conquer
is the name of the game which we see
even nowadays you know it's so
especially them you know that's hold out
the topic but in the political sphere
money politics polarization is just
insane yeah left versus right and all of
that and the friction but you know and I
see a lot of what people are going
through what the reason they're
suffering they're very various causes we
have all our wounds and traumas and all
of that but it's also because we're
trying to adjust to a world that's
completely out of tune with nature and
spirit yes and I think I might have used
the code before on your show try to
repeat Krishna motivation it's no
measure of health to be well adjusted to
a profoundly sick Society yes and I feel
lot of people they're dealing with
quote-unquote depression quote unquote
mental illness I say quote unquote
because for me it's not a it's not
something mental it's just a spiritual
disease a spiritual disconnection yes
and depression or anything we feel you
know of about ourselves our lives it's
not necessarily a mental illness or let
alone chemical imbalance
it's just the souls cried to adjust to a
world where pathology has become
normalized to not do that so depression
is actually a healthy response of a
intact spiritual immune system and there
needs to be an internal adjustment yes
and the whole point like we want to also
transcend a hope you know what we all
want to transcend o go over suffering
nobody wants to suffer we don't want to
see suffering in the world we don't like
to suffer the more that we feel
depression that's the immune systems
response to our spiritual fragmentation
should
and the more that we can observe that
and really realize it the more we can
readjust ourselves back to that divine
connection to source and then the
spiritual fragmentation heals and the
depression heals yeah it's like okay
that's that's kind of simplified view
but definitely there's truth to that but
you know if depression can also be
related to everyday stuff like also
wounds and traumas which we carry to
varying degrees you know I've talked
about this a lot with my wife Laura we
have done several podcasts about it
about trauma and trauma we all
traumatized to varying degrees wounded
right trauma there the root word is
wound and it can be big t trauma severe
trauma some of us have expense and
childhood physical sexual abuse and all
of that right but all of us carry little
T traumas just because none of our
parents have been perfect
you know we every day stress
relationship issues whatever can create
we take on a lot of stuff right and we
never fully process it emotionally so
that can also end result in depression
later on because we haven't really and
let allow ourselves feel certain
feelings we don't feel comfortable with
we avoid the avoid right it's the
constant pursue of pleasure and voidance
of pain and when and then it gets
manifest in the body it gets stuck away
to the unconscious into the shadow like
in Jungian psychology but at some point
it has to resolve itself it has to come
out you know and if you don't do it
consciously it can result also
psychological quote-unquote issues
depression in one not and our greatest
traumas actually have the greatest
treasures on the other side that's like
that's what we find now that's what I
meant mentioned before there's a whole
paradox which I notice too like we all
want to transcend suffering we don't
want to suffer and through spiritual
deepest psychotherapeutic work somatic
work and then sensory spiritual work we
can then transcend suffering right to
connect with who we truly are but
ironically in the same sense I see
myself without suffering suffering is
almost a catalyst right to push us on
the path and what I see happen on a
collective level more and more people
are suffering because there's something
bigger happened let's start from the
spiritual perspective there's a divine
force the super mental consciousness if
she urban as
your window from indigo yoga would say
is trying to anchor itself during this
time of transition right but it is
bringing up everything that is not
aligned with truth right so it is not
this like all of a sudden everything
will be in paradise but it brings up
everything we have not looked at we have
no we have avoided and a lot of a lot of
people that is very intense yeah are
they going through a lot of tribulations
you know and in the person lives
emotionally but it needs the vessel
needs to clear itself right within so we
can truly anchor the divine yeah and
that's just a very intense process right
now and and I see what's happening in
the world it's it's it's over and over
the same people get distracted by the
shadows on the wall they're influenced
by forces or cult forces they have no
awareness of there they fall into this
divide-and-conquer trap and you know
mistake symptoms for causes and Bernard
it serves its purpose it's the the
either evil serves exactly that that's
what I'm saying like your clone code
evil these forces whatever you may see
from a physical or hyper dimensional
perspective if you also study any
complete as attack teaching have the
teaching function in the in a bigger
picture of the evolution of
consciousness right there you'll
actually witness that they test your
sincerity
yeah and they tag into wherever you have
your blind spots and wounds and traumas
already so you can utilize them if you
have more of a deep awareness or cult
awareness understand universal laws most
importantly take self-responsibility
that is key because the the matrix
control system the way this operates an
unseen level they feed off of the victim
blame trap yes right it's all like self
pity victim and we always want to blame
something outside ourselves so we need
to take self-responsibility we did the
whole second episode on since yourself
work exactly that kind of ties into that
right and then we're only you guys as a
catalyst for the alchemical
transmutation because any conflict
creates friction but it's a there's an
opportunity you know even if everything
what's happening right now there's an
opportunity but it's so important to
spiritualize our being and that goes
back like we can do you know all do the
best of any social changes institutions
new systems and all of that but nothing
will change until we take is
deep look within and spiritual eyes our
being and that really BEC brings up the
question what is everyone is your
relationship with the divine in God what
do you mean right what a fundamental
questions the biggest it is what is
wrong with our society where we're not
all running around all the time asking
ourselves and each other what is your
relationship with the divine yeah if we
were doing that we want to have a
profoundly sick Society that we're
adjusted to then we would have a society
that's filled with people that are
trying to understand what is the purpose
of the entire human life and
consciousness and what is the purpose of
my individual process here yeah and that
would be a gorgeously flourishing
society these fundamental questions or
if dear thee it seems to be the most
important thing for us to focus on these
fundamental questions Who am I why am I
here why are we here what is our
connection to the divine to source and
how can we figure out how to be good and
these are very tough things what is love
these questions but these are the most
pressing questions it's just an
obsession with the question we are
obsessed with answers and we're obsessed
with cognitive ease because it doesn't
take a lot of something it's easier for
me to just take a binary answer on
something that it is for me to get into
the nuance of what is my connection to
the divine but it's worth it it's the
most important
I'm just so obsessed with transitioning
people towards those questions and they
are just extremely powerful now you have
to write the questions are most
important but these are questions you
cannot answer just with your mind or the
intellect yes right so that's that's
also the trap I don't get enough
atheists what is called in the
intellectual logical mind and you know
that what God doesn't exist and all of
that and they're also kind of looking
for some sort of biblical god of outside
themselves you know but these deeper
questions you kind of the answers are
there but they are not you don't get
them through your mind through
intellect for your rational mind it's
through an internal in internal search
your inner being your true self and that
transcends even our five senses right
it's it's tapping higher knowledge
gnosis outside or you are the you will
see the you know the mind and intellect
and logic has its place absolutely but
we need to step out of it to not make it
our mass that we have identified with it
and we'll be able to step beyond it
that's in certain esoteric practices
deep meditation they can connect you to
something much higher and deeper within
you and then you realize as I realized
in myself here come actually face to
face with the illusion of control mmm is
that your shoddy said the deeper go into
like truly find a connection to throws
the divine God what whatever name with
us names you know language is very
limited as well to name it you know the
Dow that can be named is not the dow so
really falling to all these paradoxes
and Cowen's and and all of that right so
we're just you know the finger pointing
at the moon is not the moon right and
all that these these analogies but once
you dive deeper us there's something
else in charge here actually that's
something much bigger happen in which
none of us have any control over and
then you even say who is the I to begin
with that's the biggest question I mean
they're deeper most of what you think
who you are it's just the accumulation
of experiences memories and lot of stuff
you have learned that you were
programmed breath is not even yawn stuff
and that's how the matrix corner code
works as well because you've movement
programmed
we've believes ideas since childhood to
education through and you know official
culture as I call it entertainment news
that are not even that are so removed
from truth that are not even our own
cortical views right it is really just a
program and then we identify with it we
identify with beliefs we identify with
identifications and that's a trap of
identification you know even when you
ask yourself Who am I and then you come
face to face with you know as something
obvious for example to me anyways like
you call yourself an American like you
know what you know what is that that's
an artificial belief because this is
just based on art and artificial
whatever basically once we start way
bullying
you labeled here yeah you're more than
all of that yeah you know you're not
like you're not you're not your passport
right you are God and to activate that
within every single human that's born
into the world I want to I want to
actually talk about that with you so
we're all coming from the source we're
all figuring out what our purpose is who
we are and what is your relationship
with what does it feel like to you to be
connected to this higher purpose for you
to know yourself this gnosis what is it
like for you to I have identified what
your North Star is what your divine
purpose is and what does it feel like
well for me it's an ongoing process
there's also I'm not yet awake in the
true meaning of the word by the stretch
of the imagination enlightened right but
I had certain moments I can see a
trajectory there's some sort of
development some sort of evolution
synchronicities come you know and also
you had my reflection I do something I
work with recapitulation like looking
back into oh hi buddy we have a little
visit made an appearance on our show
guest appearance by Charlie thinking
about the divine you know life is
spelled backwards is God right so there
you go buddy else is gonna say about
recapitulation like reflecting back
because what I wrote is in my own
process the whitening process is not
something you find yourself somewhere
else you know where you are in the midst
of life by the second spirit spiral I
can say out and in and avoiding and
expanse in our level so I have a have a
widening X
view of my life and or expansion beyond
my little self and I reflect back I can
see that there was another force a
higher force guiding me sometimes tough
grace sometimes divine grace to do the
work I'm doing now because I've said
this oh I never truly planned as a
career movie to do what I'm doing right
I was like involved in music in in my
20s and focused on that but then through
my own suffering still not finding
happiness contentment I'd started to
question though deepen that put me on
this path but I noticed many judges in
my players were like it's the it's the
paradox between destiny predestination
and free world yes but there's such a
thing as true freewill right because
that's the illusion of the ego
personality then believes itself to
completely free and independent and this
in the lives under the separation of
under the illusion of separation yeah
right but when I really dive in my
meditation and contemplate on the my
trajectory there has been something else
guiding me moving in synchronistically
the same time also working out my karma
based on a universal law of cause and
effects a lot of things that happen were
already set in place eelain's ago right
but the mind it kind of conceptualizes
understand it's beyond so much comes
into the equation the mind cannot grasp
because the mind is also caught in this
illusion of linear time all right so yes
what I've also in my own process you
know now I'm like I was over the past
four five years gotten deeper into the
integral yoga of Sri Aurobindo the
mother just like you know for me the
have at the highest teaching to this
date and what she or Bindo has
achievements in his lifetime to really
not only connect to the super mental
consciousness but really downloaded so
to speak into the collective is just
astonishing
and another recitation and so but it is
you know but when I find myself more
aligning with divine will there's
something higher that it's not about my
personal was not pushing my worlds
through the world right so my meditation
practice I make a conscious connection
to the divine what what am I here to do
to be of service and the way I
experience is very subtle it's also this
the subtle experience of seeing
and feeling the interconnection of all
that is right there there's no
separation in my own it is not this room
wha it may you know epiphany
enlightening experience I have it
happens on subtle levels and I start to
must see the divine and others and I see
also the anti divine forces which reopen
and many others attack teachers have
talked about that in opposition right
which ironically also expression of the
f1 but removed very you know because
everything is one but very far removed
right there's like in in a rebellion
against the one and they're trying to
keep us in this egoistic egotistical
selfish frequency of the matrix that
thrives on separation and just lower
nature indulgence and all of that but I
don't notice that no one is going to
bail us out right that's also the the
ridges dogmatic Savior program obviously
no political that someone should lead it
the way and get us out of here but it no
it's about our we are own saviors and
leaders but the way out is truly like on
a personal collective level is once we
really make the step and really anchor
the divine and goes back to the question
who is God Who am I the true this that
question can open up is the gateway to
heaven so to speak but also can open
will open up a can of worms because it
will bring up everything you have
avoided mmm that looked at things you
have lighted in yourself right in order
to anchor the divine we need to do that
clearing that's a difficult work you
know it's not like the New Year said you
just like meditate all of sudden bring
the light love and bliss you know my
wife she's a she's a meditation teacher
she studied deeply in Tibetan Buddhism
and meditation is attacked Tibetan
Buddhist and somatic meditations in our
own process and if the people should
work so if you actually made it hit
correctly it brings up your [ __ ] if you
had a comfortable process right I mean
there will be more like you know in
quote-unquote awakening enlightening
quote-unquote experiences as well about
it will bring everything that is in the
way right off truly anchoring and
sending the vine and what is also
important it's not about that's why she
openers work and integral yoga are so
profound because he's very critical of a
lot of Eastern traditions and spiritual
practice in the past their status is
impaired there was it was all about
avoiding
life an escaping life like no we need to
anchor the divine here in everyday life
to spiritualize the world and ourselves
is not about escaping anything it's not
about going to the cave and just or does
what he go just reach Samadhi nirvana
which he has achieved we need to go
beyond that and anchor it in here and
become conscious vessels of the divine
and as individuals transduces yeah and
we all have there now that's the more we
get in touch then we become lifted our
divine essence then we become more where
else to bring up not only clear selves
from all the stuff that's in the way our
wounds and traumas and and our you know
quote unquote conditioning programming
but we become more in touch with our
unique gifts you know which we've become
individual transducers off of the divine
force and then you come more in touch
with something only you can provide
it's also really the key to cancel out
any form of comparison with others yeah
any form of competition yes does if
you're truly land that's you know the
matrix still thrives too much on
competition there's no neke expression
within all of us to bring our gift and
then the gift is uniquely different from
the others and then the the process of
doing a really sincere hard work of
inner management and inner engineering
to connect with that divine do the
clearing for that unique gift to be
expressed fully and to find the
synchronicities along the way to treat
it like we're leveling up and that we
need to get to expressing our gift
otherwise we look back 70 years and we
say what was I doing and so that whole
process of identifying that were come
from source that we identify we know
thyself and then we go through the
process of self work it's also very
important when you're a tuning fork like
you said you can go out to the cave but
the real challenge is to be a de tuning
fork
in the control system and do your best
at actually raising the conscious
evolution of yourself and others in the
control system and it's also something
to balance out because our recording
studio used to be right in downtown San
Francisco it's really hard to be a
tuning fork right in the middle of a
problem it's very you're in Topanga and
it's easier to be a tuning fork you're
not too far from the metropolis but
you're way more immersed in nature and
that helps your spiritual evolution and
it helps you bring your gifts but you're
also not all the way out in the cave
either yeah yes exactly now it's not
about escaping into nature away you know
because I was like in my ways you know
I'm a body working at also to body work
energy work and you know you know work
you know a lot of my business is also on
the internet with my website of him you
know and all that and at some point I
thought well I could just leave to Costa
Rica live on the beach get away from
everything or Bali and whatnot
you know but deep inside my said no this
is I need to be where needed it's not
around to me it's not like my ego what
you know that's what I meant also we get
too much attached to what you know the
ego wants one thing right what it thinks
it needs but the soul you know that's
your true being that's what you need to
follow and many of us were here come to
put into places where we need it it's
not about escape we didn't come here for
a vacation and it's we need to take care
of ourselves absolutely right don't come
for the vacation came for this ultimate
grand challenge exactly it's it's also
but of course we need to take care of
ourselves be discerning not fall into
the trap of mechanical revolution like
the trap of a revolutionary mind and all
this like you know what even should have
been called the useless action and just
you know it's just coming from doing
doing but it's not coming from a deeper
level of being and connection yeah and
so a couple questions yeah I'm on the
source playing out right now and being
this beautiful painting with different
brushstrokes as our individual
contributions or a symphony with our
individual instruments and notes being
played is it already a predetermined
process and that we express ourselves
along the way what is free wills role in
that process it seems as though
potentially that the purpose of that
evil is for the these bifurcating
moments of deciding if something that we
want to do is good or something that we
want to do as a matrix control
temptation so talk to us about
predetermine ISM well that's a big
question it's a good one so you know for
me I'm just speaking for my own level of
being level understanding why I'm at I'm
not claiming to know it all but you know
yes like I said for me most part free
will is an illusion
you know because who is who am i who is
doing it right I may act something but
what I've realized through my own inner
experiences meditations and whatnot in
our deeper experiences and will confirm
through esoteric teachings especially
also like in lately guarding into more
like I mentioned Chagall yoga free open
and the mother is that we are
transducers of high energies yes
so the concept we are just transducers
right I recommend this the like you know
like I mentioned that we and control is
an illusion EBRD shanti said the more
you come deeper to your true being you
realize the illusion of control that you
are never in control to begin with and
that's very offensive to the ego it
doesn't like to hear that right like
what do you mean I want what I want and
I'm doing this but you know but well as
long as we in the outside surface
consciousness assume and I said you know
we have which is like 0.1% of what's
really going on behind the scenes so to
speak right on unconscious level and
even higher levels of what has actually
initiated the action because we're
constantly subjected to all kinds of
forces so the more we unconscious the
more via mechanical different unless we
have a connection to a true soul the
psychic being to the divine
the more mechanic were more driven by a
more like many people are mechanically
through our wounds and traumas trying to
recompensate something we have lost in
childhood you know like trying to fill
this hole within ourselves meaning we
constantly look externally for happiness
as I'm gonna keep doing that we're more
subjected to the quote unquote evil or
whatever called hostile adverse forces a
street vendor would call them or they
have been given different names
throughout the ages right so through
matrix temptations
you know then very subtly then we look
excessively you know money sex fame my
that's how things were being getting you
know tempted with there's nothing evil
with money in itself it's just when the
greed comes in and more and more
materialism and try to make yourself
feel better by you know just
materialistic stuff whatever right and
then fame you really like concern then
more people like you that you want to be
have a certain image to make yourself
feel better
and all these hooks right do take they
will remove us more from who we truly
are
you know and remove us from the kingdom
within where we all fulfilled within
yeah so the more we're coming from that
place then we are subjected by these
forces and you know no free will there
at all under the illusion of free will
but we like puppets on strings
manipulated and that's how the matrix
keeps humanity in check so we can be
trends there can be and can be a
transducer for our own divine potential
exactly that's that the other side so
once we but engage in in the great work
of the alchemists the inner work but
whatever traditionally you know doing
the true yoga which is move truly
aspirational surrender to the divine
you're like the Union threefold like Sri
Aurobindo said it's the aspiration to
the divine the rejection of anything
that's not your true nature and
resisting the temptations the
interference is yes and then the true
surrender when you become truly Messel
you know and let the divine anchor and
work through you then you you know it's
still not you're doing it because but
you offer yourself your vessel for the
divine work and then that's where you
can also access the true joy and bliss
and beauty of who you truly are because
the natural state of your soul of your
psyche being is pure joy it's exciting
it's joyful life for life but for
everything for all of existence but it
does not
that mass it does not depend on anything
external yes so if you still like in the
game come within the kingdom within the
gauge of X if you still if you feel
happy and great about yourself great but
if it depends on anything outside on a
relationship or stuff you have or life
circumstances its did not still not the
true thing recipe for disaster
right yes so I'm not saying not to like
enjoy it's not to not enjoy the material
world that's also the distortion at
alpha of spirituality like enjoy but
don't make it attach yourself as the
source for the true fulfillment
yes ik yes so we being transducers the
more we aligned with what the divine
creative expression is our unique paint
stroke our unique instrument or note
that we're playing in the symphony the
more it seems like we are just
surrendered to that process without a
free will at the same time what I'd like
to know how people read these
bifurcating moments example you have
your cosmic matrix podcast you maybe
need to do four hours of prep for one of
your guests or you have the choice of
going on a hike for four hours or doing
yoga for four hours or hanging out with
lore for hours etc right how do you make
those bifurcating decisions on when to
focus on who the prep for the work for
the or the the connection to the divine
in nature with your partner etc how do
you work that's a good question and
usually like it really depends on my own
connection to my true self to the divine
so for me very important is having a
spiritual practice like each morning
even before you came yes I too much ego
my chi gong tai chi helps in moving
meditation or it to relax the body relax
the mind
followed by meditation usually meditate
sometimes okay it had been a mom ten
minutes makes them usually
excuse me 20 minutes or 30 minutes and
then do that meditation also like I do
our self breath work to really like
relax more my vagus nerve to physiologic
to get myself in the deep stay
and then I scan my body to sematic
what's happening my body is there any
signs and then I do the aspiration the
deeper aspiration Devine really calling
the divine force and like you know
asking questions intentions and like
what that's what do you want for me to
that aligning with consciously but
consciously with divine will like its
die world not my world which at the
beginning when I said years ago was in
the sitcom's is difficult because the
ego in their mind like doesn't trust it
like the egos like no I want what I want
I don't you know who are you divine so
it's like in these moments then I go
deeper and then the answer comes of what
I need to do right where I said come for
comes from it's sometimes it's just it's
the deeper inspiration like some body
this is what I need to do there's no
question and it's not a mental decision
yes then where does it come from then
heart God like it's like yeah it's
sometimes this you know the super like
it comes from above you know like the
higher mind so to speak you know like
you know is the descent of this of the
divine force confirmed by coma then then
the heart opening and then also even
just the guts you know the intuitive
sense so to speak but the whole body
what excites me as well like I'm just
like this is what needs to be done and
if there's any moment of like okay I'm
not quite sure on the other hand I'm not
what I want to say as well I'm not
always there tuned in sometimes and I
confuse myself should I do this and I
three different things at the same time
and you know and I get a bit and get my
own anxiety and I'm not enlightened
right I have my own stuff still coming
up I get triggered and like I'm get
tired like [ __ ] you know and then my
mind you know it's very I have a very
self-critical mind that kind of like you
know puts me even more negative state
and have to watch out for that and then
maybe interferences so it is a battle
sometimes i'm not always line up i'm not
always like flowing on the dow like hi
you know yes certainly not you see it's
a challenge then happen that's yeah I
mean confusion exactly and then being
more gentle with myself but it's like
the sincerity like Annie I know if I
don't keep up my own spiritual practice
then it comes up and even that I needs
to extend beyond the spiritual one our
prices have in the morning every day you
know when I come like you know for me
it's like that aspiration you know this
to source to something else that kind of
guides me and then the answers come and
then also life arranges itself naturally
right yeah and we see this also like
Lauren I when we do a podcast certain
topics come up with feel very excited by
sometimes it comes through difficult
lessons sometimes it comes through ways
like hardships we experience in our own
process and whatnot or my own process
but that's a gift like what I learned
from and then you know a lot of my
writings and films have done videos I've
done in the past or essays came from a
place of suffering right of like you
know and then the creative process of
writing helps you to heal and then
understand and then that's where I find
my gift as well - you know - for my work
and maybe inspire and help others that
way yes
now let's touch on as we go on this path
of spiritual awakening and we're
identifying our diff'ent our divine
purpose it's channeling through us we're
transducer for that more and more
awakened we become and more and more we
are discerning of what is serving a
purpose towards spiritual awakening
around the world and more and more we're
discerning what is not and then what is
not serving a purpose of conscious
evolution around the world those are
those matrix control vectors off of our
paths of divine alignment now what are
the most critical principles to embody
for discernment you gave the list of the
money power and sex
that these the main vectors that can
take us off of the path that we play
with the constructs of the control
system but we're also simultaneously
building new codes to maximize spiritual
evolution and to obsolete some of the
old archaic codes that exist among us to
speak to us about that the control
system in those vectors and also just
what are the forces where are they
coming from were they part of source the
initial creation process was that there
will be these evil forces here and they
will serve this purpose of consciousness
and light being able to evolve more
effectively because of the those forces
yeah I mean for anybody who is not
familiar my work I mean I first
encouraged to go to my website van of
reality comm there's a whole also
lecture I gave a couple years ago called
the matrix control system and the path
towards Awakening which lays out what we
just talked about in your question and
way more depth and there's way more my
website because it's hard to summarize a
lot of these things especially people
have not come across this topic at all
at all but what I call the matrix
control system we see it on a basic 3d
level of institutions governments would
never who don't have our best interests
in heart and we're kind of controlled on
some level right and live tune all of
that but I talk from an esoteric from
the Cole perspective that there's the
unseen occult matrix that works through
humanity before called hyper dimensional
forces entities that have given
different names throughout history you
know like this mentioned trio bender
integrally or integral integral yoga
calls them you know called hostile or
adverse forces the adroit forces that
have hijacked basically it's infiltrated
or you know invaded humanity through our
own minds also which are parts of
creation these are this part like that's
you know that's get into very it's all
very paradoxical yes a you know
you know and and then two other
traditions you know wet eco I don't know
if your of PO TV wet Tico went eco the
Native American expression for this
alien virus that is also overtaking
humanity this predator or the Jing from
the sophist tradition or the general
often is a terrace charity tradition the
outcomes from the hematocrit ition so
you see all different ways that they
have been named but they know that what
you may ask what is their agenda alright
we seen maybe on on a 3d level of the
matrix of what the elite and the shadow
government and all of that transnational
corporations what they are there's greed
and money and all of that more power for
them but that's really just the symptom
that's just a surface because they are
just vessels of these higher demonic
suruc hostile forces and what they're
what they are trying to do with humanity
through various mechanisms control even
genetic modification to keep us in the
frequency person to keep us pitting
against each other keep us in this
perpetual loop of suffering or fighting
in you know on a global level war
interpersonal and whatnot and because it
creates a certain frequency and a loose
frequency an emotion luge which death
which sustains them it literally feeds
them so in a very basic level we are not
on top of the food chain yes and that's
what the shamans called the topic of all
topics that we are like farmed for our
you know so frequency so to speak and
the more we are transducers that
transcend that on a higher light the
true ascension of the Nuge sense but
raise our frequency not in a new age way
of just imagining love and light and
positive thoughts it's it's it's that's
the great work there's a deeper work
that's how we transcend these forces
that's how we create true harmony in the
world that's the key to reality creation
you know it's not going to happen
through external means you know it will
happen through external means but it
needs to come from this deep alignment
of being and and the connection to the
divine but I also want to point out the
important that process is a highly
individual process because we always
have to understand
we're second billion people on this
planet we invest different levels of
soul development and being and many
people who don't have a deeper spiritual
esoteric understanding fall into the
trap of hormonal homogenization of
humanity that we think everybody were
the same and we're gonna have a
collective awakening soon he's not gonna
have to you know we shove our individual
division process right there young souls
here they're soulless humans here as
well which is also a very taboo topic
you know from an esoteric perspective
and they're higher developed souls but
there's no judgment it's just the way it
is rate is right so we have to like the
work I'm doing you know natural for me
is like deserved what I'm doing but I
don't expect for anybody else to do that
if you only to find our own unique
expression yes and then specifically I
want to address this aspect of it that
there is some sort of a game of chess
let's call it or risk or whatever board
game you want to call it that is being
played on the planet yeah and that then
creation made exactly this board game to
unravel itself and as it evolves we
our transducers for either than if we've
done sincere self work we can channel
through us light and our own spiritual
awakening and others if we have not then
we can be transducers for malevolence
and then that is being played out like a
big board game on the planet yeah yeah
speak to that yeah
now it's also like the way I see these
forces you know it's almost like a bug
in the system like like a virus that has
taken over so to speak so it is about
you know in a sense then the work
becomes harder you know because it goes
way deep and we also going back to the
questions you ask to whoever whatever
but what we know have we ever asked a
question human nature for example you
know we always like say everything we
have normalized pathologies for
thousands of years we say oh this is
just eagle and all of that but you know
how we ever questioned human history
truly you know because you know there's
way more to what you know I mean
official history is late as most for the
most part and like read Epona just a
very distorted version of what truly
happened you know there goes back into
genetic modification alien intervention
in history and forbidden archeology
there's there's a book I literally
called forbidden archeology I forgot by
who it is but I recommend for people to
see about how you know we believe in the
story like Darwinism you know we even
caught in this Darwinism idea which is
also a theory right that we evolved just
from apes and all of sudden we're here
never mind the missing link the Dalai
Lama also recently said that that we've
just objectively said that it's been a
process of survival of the fittest and
that's it whereas it completely puts
compassion and cooperation and
friendship and love and harmony all to
the Sun we just we just believe it
without questioning because then I
mentioned for this matrix programming of
education academic institution than just
because everybody says that we believe
it without ever question we just we just
take it on and ultimately what is the
next
evolution then is one next one that
decide at that thing and that's why I
like again I find and I can also for you
to recommend to look a bit into the work
of sheer wind and the mother yes for me
this is the ultimate the avatar the last
avatars incarnated in this work I am
just starting to realize the work that
he has done and I hope her found it is
and however for five years how wrong go
shoot shoot Sri Aurobindo three or
banana that's you know he was like you
know in all the early early twentieth
century early tree had getting first
connection with the super mental and you
know he was a quick quick story he was a
revolutionary Indian he was he grew up
in England okay
went to get you know because that's you
know was England you know was a India
was a colony of England so his parents
put him at the Sun as an early age to
England he was grew up there you know
went to university he even taught
himself he was already so he taught
himself as a teenager he taught himself
German so he could read good thoughts in
philosophy in the original language I
mean he was already out there
then I'd Eddy around age 20 went back to
India and then had to relearn his own
language and then realized so all the
suffering and the political corruption
and what the England the English you
know the government was doing so he
became a revolutionary he was an
anarchist revolutionary even organizing
uprisings and all of that and even
atheist and then eventually got
imprisoned a few times was writings and
uprisings and then got into solitary
confinement where he found his you yoga
and had his first enlightened yeah
experience in the prison and then the
divine he would part of his path and
then the rest is kind of history but he
also talked about you know you're
brought up kerchief in Georgia at the
same time they will live you know love
about what you've been to talk about
that man is a transitional being we
haven't finished evolution correct
we are just way business in an infant
state we are mean it does not forget
that an evolution we're just so that's
also because of this or call forces
because of our technological progress of
all the gadgets we have
who are so evolved but actually it's an
externalization of the internal
technology we have disconnected from
correct and that's why you know my view
of the future of transhumanism and then
and yeah that's like the end game from
an occult matrix perspective to remove
ourselves more and more from from the
divine to remove the soul like soul
snatching to merge manner of machine so
we are being prepared as international
vessels in car bodies or clothes forces
you now because we've become so obsessed
a physical life right with the physical
body and all of that and disconnect from
what I call internal biological or
organic technology which is the own DNA
activation which is when you infuse it
to become the superhuman Superman as a
street vendor talk not in terms in the
ways Nietzsche talked about aperture
window completely spiritual eyes
demonize your being that's eternal life
right there eternal life for you
transcend death you don't need to eat
like that's the way to do it yes but now
we're caught into externalized
stabilizing it and you sleep like
obsessed youth and and you know you see
it even on a basic cosmetic surgeries
and all of that the bio hacking which
has its part but it can people can also
become so obsessed with physical used
and wanting to extend life I really then
will even accept will like increase with
the whole transhumanism obviously I
really want technologists around the
world to pay attention to what Barnard
just said this is so important it's as
though we have not evolved from
spiritual kindergarden yet we are
democratizing exponential technologies
that are godlike and these same issues
seemingly have arise in the past and
cost civilizational collapses our wisdom
has not caught up to the godlike powers
that we have and that ultimately
ultimately it is the most beautiful
thing for you to fully activate your
biological propensity from within this
full activation of your
vine potential and just be that's
eternal love that's eternal God right
there and it's so evident that from our
externalization unwritten reliance on
the technologies and the desire for all
of these externalities that make it seem
like we're more technologically advanced
meanwhile we're spiritually in
kindergarten that we are now trying to
do all the transhuman AI things and I've
actually thanks to people like you and
thanks to others that I've been studying
it's now become more and more clear that
one of my roles is to help people slow
down and connect more to the divine and
their own purpose and activate
themselves through this this natural
biological process and then to realize
that they themselves are God that they
are all that is that they don't that we
need to really slow down in our
development of these super intelligences
and these externalities that we are
giving godlike powers to because we
ourselves are not ethically or morally
or spiritually advanced enough to be
creating them so that's actually become
a massive pillar of my ethos thanks to
people like you and what is overall just
the point
the teleology the overall purpose the
meaning of this entire evolutionary
experiment creation has given us this
rock orbiting this star and these bodies
for us to experience consciousness and
it's an source with what is the point of
it you're asking me for the meaning of
life basically I cannot tell you what
the meaning of life is something
internalized each of us and you know I
just feel like you know it's God
fighting it's an icon whatever it's
beyond it's hard for me to conceptualize
even in two words right there's
something deeper
merging here like a birth of a new world
something that has never done before in
the entirety of existence so you know
it's like I like the analogy what I
heard it's like you know what we
expenses this new human the super him
what we truly were supposed to evolve
towards is beyond our imagination of
understanding it's like trying to like I
forgot to what the master said it but
it's trying to like talking about the
dog it's like trying to explain to a dog
how a boeing seven four seven works yeah
so that's the statement in right now you
know we cannot even mentally understand
it's a deeper experience but we in this
process but whatever bring out what you
talk in mention as well we are very
extremely critical times right now the
time of transition and why all paths
from the bigger picture perspective will
lead towards full civilization awakening
but it's like you know what the mothers
for me regret I said it's unconscious
yoga like yeah there's unconscious
mechanical evolution but we can expedite
it you can like if we more consciously
align then we make sure the goal will be
achieved without falling into what the
other many other spiritual teachings
prophecies have hinted at falling into
another dark net of the civilization yes
you know off you know what even you read
an esoteric Christianity which is the
true it Christian teachings been way
before that the church have has hijacked
it I talked about that the divine may
will press the reset button
if we don't heed the voice of the vine
which is already calling us yes
you know she openeth mentioned something
similar like you know because as when
you look at you mentioned history is
cyclical you know there have been other
civilizations you know the we our modern
respected history bookstore mentioned
and you know people think it's a sci-fi
but look at that lantus that was also
when you research Atlantis has been a
highly developed technological
civilization similar to us and through
abuse of technology it's um destroyed
itself so if you know there's the higher
power which is in charge here if we
don't learn our lessons step up and
really align with who we truly are
we will not destroy yourself the divine
will okay we the experiment failed again
we got to have to start over again
so that's the choice is ours there's up
or down you know this future is not set
in stone but that's the critical moments
were in write down and and they
eventually yeah all passive to the same
but we can you know it may take it can
take a couple of hundred years maybe
just a hundred years or again more
thousands of years and we need to have
way more cycles of incarnation to do it
over and over again until when do we get
the message right and what is that then
that goal that we're striving for the
spiritual awakening of us individually
as well as collectively harmonizing that
as a pinnacle planet
II can see on like it's also again this
it's it's really hard for me even to
understand on their own on the basic
that mind I am in right now on the level
of being but it's imagine transcending
death there's no death because you have
a semi in physical body like shreya
Pinto and the mother talked about which
by their owner point out when I
mentioned who don't know their work it's
not your typical guru and or whatever
Eastern stuff I mean you know I reread
his work in def and he won you know you
will see that the profound teachings he
he gave to the world but in terms of the
superhuman there won't be any organs
anymore right will be energy centers so
it there will be instant telepathy there
will be you know by local you can be at
any point where you want you know appear
just by the way you think when you're
fully aligned with the source this it's
it's it's a complete utopian service to
other society where everybody is exactly
doing what they are supposed to do from
is higher perspective yes
it's community there's no need for any
currency for any economic system
there's none you know these are very
archaic things we still operate within
yes right there's complete deletion of
any competition or regard for win or
loss or whatever it's it's way beyond
it's it's it's the final you know
manifestation of the divine in in every
single aspect of life and that's the
best I can summarize that's well said
yeah that's well said that every single
child that's being born into world's
being born into a
social fabric that is literally the most
conducive possible to the divine being
expressed through each of us as a
transducer I love that and then that
being like this ultimate playground of
each of us bringing our own gifts and
transcending the archaic infrastructures
and codes that we have now Bernard how
many episodes has have been now of the
cosmic matrix podcast where you guys
have 13 episodes 13 episodes it's
happening weekly right now I've it every
two weeks every two weeks so this has
been really fun seeing your diverse
guests that have been coming on the
cosmic matrix podcast and you're hosting
that with Laura your wife and so teach
us about what it's been like having the
different guests on learning from them
playing the games of tennis with them
kind of up leveling your consciousnesses
at the same time yeah
well mostly we have we've just restarted
to having guests you know Laura had with
a friend Kelsey they were doing and
doing a workshop together and they
talked deeply about the toxic feminine
out there which is the amazing podcast
and highly recommend they go deep into
their cult as well though not just only
from a you know official culture
perspective because specially nowadays
most people talk about toxic masculinity
but nobody sees a toxic feminine which
were so they had an amazing talk my
first guest was Tom Montag it's a fellow
researcher and proof who have heard a
lot from learned a lot from and have
been in contact you know over yeah I
first came across 20 years ago and
connected with him like over 10 and 11
years ago so all over kind of use it
very well with an amazing talk together
but most of the podcasts are just
Lorelai talking because we are very you
know that's how we talk about every day
we pick a topic whatever going through
me well it very good like exploring and
and having a conversation about it in a
very natural setting and people seem to
enjoy it and we will you go we go deep
we going to call forces the matrix but
we also talk about trauma
yes won't work basic psychotherapeutic
somatic work
we talk about our latest podcast was
tying it all together trommel called
forces and the matrix how it all works
together we talked about psychedelics we
talked about spiritual bypassing the
new-age I mean you can you can find out
my website you know the first hour is
free you know to the podcast outlets
iTunes or on YouTube as well the second
hour we usually go deeper and more
personal that's for the membership of my
website yes you know because we want to
have a safe container to explore yes
topics that may be way too out there for
the public so to speak but it's nice to
evolve and I start to have more guests
and I like you know the you know the
idea of just interviewing people and I
don't know when this will be released
but my latest guest I had I just
recorded it was Paul Levy I have him on
and he's author of dispelling with Tico
the the curse of evils and his book
quantum revelation so it was very
fascinating so we're gonna keep doing
like write together and then sometimes
having guests and it's just go by
inspiration or whatever topic way into
it at any given moment yes yeah the game
of going back and forth with Laura as
well as with the guests and actually
videotaping that and putting that out to
share with people I'm so happy that you
guys decided to do that we were talking
about that when we were doing her first
interview together about the importance
of you sharing these messages more and
you've really embarked on that what's
POTUS I'm very excited for the viewers
to check it out again that's on a veil
of reality dot-com for everyone that
wants to check out Bernards work let's
uh let's wrap I think we covered a
really good amount of of stuff on this
one another one of those like we both
went out synthesized more came back and
it's late yeah yeah it's tough sometimes
we know that's a good question a big
question so okay I gotta like synthesize
it like this where I'm at and like you
know because I'm also you see to my
other people who know my work my ass is
that tend to be long because I want to
like make it tight so you know
you've also give references because
these are big topics and I'm like you
know you know me like I'm changing the
my work as an expression where I met and
it keeps evolving as you can see you
know there's a reason why I mentioned
she have been to enter go to yoga a lot
because that's really what I'm diving
deep into right now you know I'm just
like I'm not never taking one thing as a
foundation I'm not I don't have an
automatic Express and I know this is the
way but you know there's also divine
guidance you know a certain maybe you
can information teachings yes come
across just the right time they do me
that's the perfect yeah place where I am
at right now in my stage of evolution
this was another critical point is that
you are doing like the Greek call
eclectic oh so you're very eclectic
you're pulling from different sources
you're syncretic you're pulling from
different areas and synthesizing and
you're not labeling yourself with any
labels and that's that's extremely
important and I think it's a massive
inspiration to people to parse what
exists for the most optimal signal for
them to connect with source for them to
to express themselves divinely on in in
the lifetime that they have here and
yeah I'm looking forward to the next to
the next round and to see where we are
I'm sure that you can see that like for
me you're a you're a little older than I
am and you've had more time to see the
world and whatnot and but for me
especially like I think it was about a
year and almost a half ago or so that we
did our first sit down together and back
then it was very interesting seeing
re-watching Andry listening that just
how much I had no [ __ ] idea you did
very well
I mean if y'all give on it that's all so
you're done you you have a gift right
but also we're constantly learning and
fine-tuning and then you know especially
of that kind of work it's like you know
I want to get to these these topics it's
not just about the intellectual
information and itself
and it's just like okay there's a deeper
inner experience that needs to come with
it so to speak
yes yes and that that and that deeper
inner experience was the second round
that we had together after the first one
did a really good job at unpacking who
you are in your work the second one was
about that sincere self work in the
process of the journey and this was a
lot on dis overall spiritual awakening
I'm just really grateful that we're able
to continue doing this I hope that the
viewers thank you everyone for tuning in
we really appreciate it we'd love to
hear your thoughts in the comments below
in the episode let us know you're
thinking about spiritual awakening and
all the topics that we talked about with
Barnard today we would love for you to
check out the links in the bio again
veil of reality comm check that out all
the articles the videos the essays the
cost of matrix podcasts go and subscribe
to their channel like their videos going
to share their videos share more content
around out more conversations around the
world with your friends your families
co-workers people online on social media
about the topics we talked about today
about source about our divine connection
to our ultimate purpose here about the
matrix control system about the light
and dark forces at play what is the
purpose of all this these profound
questions ask them up to yourself and
ask them to each other more often and
also support Bernard's work you can
support his work on his website it's
critical to get it out to more people
you can support simulation our links are
below as well support these artists
entrepreneurs the spiritual leaders and
organizations around the world that you
believe in you can find our Pay Pal
patreon cryptocurrency links below as
well as you can design cool merch you
get paid all that stuff's below and go
and build the future everyone manifest
your dreams into the world we love you
very much thank you for tuning in and
we'll see you soon
peace
thank you
good job brother the job that's good job
yeah good enough yeah I felt really